komm zurück bei uns ja und jetzt ist ihr
außenminister heiko maas herzlich
willkommen ich habe morgen
bevor wir mit ihnen sprechen möchten wir
ihnen und den zuschauern ein mann
vorstellen dessen schicksal
stellvertretend für so viele steht die
derzeit verzweifelt versuchen in letzter
minute vor den taliban aus kabul zu
fliehen fahrer zeit ist pizzabäcker aus
nordrhein-westfalen er reiste nach
afghanistan um seine frau und seinen
zweijährigen sohn ibrahim nach
deutschland zu holen aber er bekam keine
aufenthaltsgenehmigung für die beiden
und bevor er die bürokratischen hürden
nehmen konnte hatten die taliban die
macht erobert und er saß mit seiner
familie in der falle dann begann die
odyssee nach deutschland die er mit
seinem handy dokumentiert hat
es sind bilder die schockieren die den
schrecken auf kabul straßen nur vermuten
lassen
auf seiner flucht zum flughafen in kabul
film fahrer zeit die leichen der
menschen die es nicht geschafft haben
fahrrad wagt den gefährlichen weg zum
flughafen er will seine frau und seinen
sohn in die sichere heimat bringen nach
deutschland die familie schafft es an
den taliban vorbei als sie am flughafen
ankommen herrscht dort chaos
super für mich
alles studiert also
alle flüge sind weg es gibt keine flug
bis wobei alle menschen sind hier
mehrere stunde wollte ja ausländische
gibt auch er nicht niemand kein
flughafen personal und keine truppen in
sichtweite und jeder versucht sich noch
einen platz in einem der wenigen
flugzeuge zu erkämpfen
[Musik]
bisher komplett
[Applaus]
fahrrads und seine familie schaffen es
am ende noch in ein flugzeug das sie
nach usbekistan bringt
selbst auch die fußgänger sind sitzen
die menschen so sie das so sieht auch
dass menschen
nur mit viel glück und unterstützung von
einem freund aus deutschland landen
fahrrad seine frau und sein zweijähriger
sohn drei tage später in frankfurt am
main
ja mal was geht ihnen durch den kopf
wenn sie diese geschichte hören und
sehen das ist schrecklich und ehrlich
gesagt es sind bilder die uns und auch
mich seit tagen verfolgen es gibt
bedauerlicherweise viele dieser fälle
versuchen wir nicht nur wir sondern
andere länder auch mit allem was uns zur
verfügung steht in der zeit die uns noch
bleibt so viele menschen aus afghanistan
ausfliegen zu können wir haben jetzt
etwa 3800 ausfliegen können davon 351
deutsche staatsbürger wir stehen noch
mit 100 staatsbürgern und ihren familien
in kontakt deren standort ja auch wissen
und
die wir auch heute versuchen wieder
einigermaßen sicher an den flughafen zu
bringen um sie dann auf eine unserer
maschinen zu verteilen genauso natürlich
auch die mitbürger anderer länder die
wir mitnehmen anderen ländern eben auch
unsere staatsbürger mit und mittlerweile
auch über 2000 afghanische männer und
frauen und kinder die wir aus kabul
ausgeflogen
die amerikaner haben gesagt dass sie bis
zum 31 august diese militärische
evakuierungsaktion fortsetzen werden im
moment wird in washington darüber
gesprochen ob das verlängert werden kann
aber das muss man auch im zusammenhang
sehen mit der sicherheitssituation die
es am flughafen gibt das heißt es bleibt
abzuwarten wie viele zeit bleibt noch um
die sicherheit der streitkräfte die dort
sind zu gewährleisten aber natürlich
auch die sicherheit der menschen die wir
aus fliegen wollen das ist eine sehr
sehr schwierige abwägung die treffen wir
vor allen dingen zusammen mit den
vereinigten staaten aber auch
großbritannien das sind die länder die
mit uns die meisten kräfte dort haben
und ich gehe davon aus dass es heute im
laufe des tages eine entscheidung in
washington darüber geben wird ob die
evakuierungsaktion verlängert wird oder
nicht aber man glaube ich muss jetzt
schon sagen selbst wenn sie bis zum 31
august geht oder noch ein paar tage
länger das wird nicht reichen um all
diejenigen die wir aus fliegen wollen
oder die die vereinigten staaten
ausgeben wollen in dieser zeit aus dem
land zu bringen
und deshalb haben wir zusammen mit den
usa und großbritannien jetzt begonnen
überlegungen anzustellen wie auch nach
der militärischen
evakuierung
leute aus afghanistan raus gebracht
werden können dass der flughafen zivil
weiterbetrieben werden kann dafür sind
unsere partner und wir
miteinander einig dass wir dafür bereit
werden auch dafür die organisation zu
stellen damit das ende der militärischen
evakuierung nicht das ende der
möglichkeiten ist menschen aus
afghanistan raus zu bringen man wird die
militärische evakuierung beendet wir
haben informationen dass die bundeswehr
möglicherweise noch vor den amerikanern
das land verlassen wird das wird so sein
wenn am 31
beendet wird von den amerikanern werden
die amerikaner sicherlich ein zwei tage
brauchen um
ausschließlich ihr militär noch
auszufliegen das heißt es würde bedeuten
dass die evakuierung zeitlich
möglicherweise etwas früher wäre aber
das können wir abschließend erst sagen
wenn wir wissen wann der amerikaner
exakt gehen und ich gehe davon aus dass
heute im laufe des tages auch eine
entscheidung geben das ist das für ein
signal lammers wenn einen terroristen
diktieren wie man sich verhalten soll
wenn
taliban-regime
taliban-anführer sagen ihr aus dem
westen ihr verlasst unser land sonst
passiert schlimm ist das ist doch
verkehrte welt das ist noch viel
schlimmer als verkehrte welt aber die
lage ist nun einmal so und wenn man vor
der alternative steht mit den taliban
nicht zu sprechen weil das wofür sie
stehen man selber für schrecklich
empfindet und ist deshalb nicht mehr
möglich sein wird menschen aus
afghanistan auszufliegen dann wüsste ich
immer wie meine entscheidung ist und so
handeln wir ja auch wir sprechen ja
selber auch mit den taliban um überhaupt
zu gewährleisten dass deutsche
staatsbürger an den flughafen kommen und
die kontrollpunkte der taliban
durchqueren können aber auch bei unseren
ortskräfte und insofern es ist alles
schrecklich
das ist so weit gekommen ist aber wir
haben überhaupt keine alternative wenn
wir menschen da raus bringen wollen das
auch mit den taliban vor ort zu
verhandeln erklären sie uns ich finde
auch dass die auswahl die er dann auch
in der politik verantwortung getroffen
werden muss wie findet die stadt als
wäre jetzt irgendwie zufällig kontakt
zur botschaft kriegt oder zu ihnen krieg
das glück gehabt und kann es vielleicht
noch schaffen in der ablaufenden zeit
mehr kein kontakt kriegt weil das handy
nicht funktioniert weil er in seiner
wohnung sitzt weil er sich nicht aus der
hat einfach pech gehabt und muss in der
hölle bleiben wir haben ja nicht erst in
den letzten 24 stunden damit angefangen
es gibt listen in denen die deutschen
staatsbürger geführt werden mit denen
wir auch in kontakt stehen wir haben
auch permanent nachgefragt ob welche
dazugekommen sind dh diese listen werden
permanent
evakuiert und sie können wir davon
ausgehen dass alle die da sind ein
großes interesse haben und alles
mögliche anstellen um uns in kontakt zu
kommen und den wir kennen die standorte
wir haben in den letzten tagen die
person informiert wie sie an den
flughafen kommen wie das prozedere da
ist es ist leider nicht bei allen
gelungen deshalb werden wir auch in den
kommenden tagen noch einiges zu tun
haben aber wir haben 351 staatsbürger
mit ihren familien rausgebracht und wir
werden noch über 100 mit ihren familien
in den kommenden tagen raus bringen
müssen sie haben auch gerade die
geschichte von fahrrad gesehen und wir
wollen jetzt noch mal live zu ihm
schalten erwartet wie geht es ihnen
jetzt und ihrer familie ja hallo geht
nur auf jeden fall viel besser kann als
und hallo leute und wir sind glücklich
ihn heimat in deutschland bis hin zu
hause seit wochen nicht aus und
bedrohen von die taliban was gekommen zu
hause muss man raus
in intervallen richtig schlechte zeit
wir werden schlechten nacht gewesen muss
mitternacht muss man haus verlassen eine
ruhige ecke gehen aber da war es schon
lange nicht mehr die rede war so schnell
gewesen durchschnitt die kabel am kabel
komplett aufmarschiert um gekommen alle
militärabkommen und keine sicherheit
gewesen ich war auch der flughafen
gemessen zurück gesehen das war eine
ziemlich flugzeug gewesen afghanischer
airlines war flugzeuge gestartet war
aber keine pilot und niemanden gewesen
und ein flugzeug zu fliegen und wir
müssen wieder maschinen raus um wieder
zum militär flugzeug
laufen mit meiner frau und
meinen mann familie war alle da und bin
ich noch ich habe nicht geschafft die
leute dinge weil ich habe wie gesagt
problem mit visum gehabt zum glück meine
heiratsurkunde gewesen und personal
alles was man von mir und meinen sohn
afghanischer personalausweis gewesen
geburtsurkunde und britischer und es hat
irgendwie aufgenommen um deutsche
bundeswehr gebracht
und drohte ist zwei tage gebracht ist
nach deutschland und wir haben zwölf
stunden zu ewigen baustellen gewesen und
jetzt alles geflogen nach deutschland
wollen die leute leute wir haben auch
mitgekriegt man die ganze von minister
vertreten unser wohnhaus ist ein
geschäft wo man strebe vater ist das
entzündet wurden weil die suche nach uns
und man schwägerin weil ich zarafa die
ich habe mit abbauenden aufgesprochen
freitag ist das und thomas lammertz mann
freund alles auch geschrieben ich hoffe
diese familie hast wie ihnen die
sicherheit kommt oder bringen kann und
dafür anbieten dafür die menschen sind
gebildet die seine oma ist das und frau
die stelle nicht dass in afghanistan er
sei ja mehr und länger leben wenn
sie mich hören können wir haben jetzt
und sie haben jetzt die einmalige
gelegenheit mit dem bundesaußenminister
zu sprechen herr maas sie haben die
gelegenheit herrn z zu erklären warum es
zu diesen versäumnissen gekommen ist
warum alles so lange gedauert hat warum
er auch in diese falle gelaufen ist ja
wir wissen schon seit ein mehrere jahre
mit herzlichen dank aber ich würde herrn
mas gerne wissen die antwort zu geben
ich finde aber kurz erklären warum bin
ich nach afghanistan geflogen wie auch
welche grund ich bin seit sechs wochen
nach afghanistan geflogen seit drei
jahren verheiratet mann frau und ich hab
mein zweieinhalbjährigen sohn in
afghanistan und welt gekommen mein
papierkram ist das so lange gebraucht
bis eine visum erhalten und ich habe
heiratsurkunde alles habe ich
vorbereitet habe ich auch abgegeben weil
afghanische botschaft alten deutsche
botschaft in afghanistan gab es nicht
wir müssen nach pakistan islamabad
fliegen und dort aber mehrere tausend
euro geld abgeben noch die leute was wir
unsere ob ihr aufnehmen pakistan und
seit eineinhalb jahre warte ich schon
immer noch drauf bist in eine visum
termin gibt ich sage mal gesagt und auch
danach fliegen sechs wochen gemacht aber
bis heute leider haben wir keinen
abstieg ihr seid ihr seid es sind sehr
viele bürokratische umstände wir haben
wir haben glaube ich verstanden wo das
problem ist herr maas also zunächst
normal und ich glaube es gibt niemanden
innerhalb der bundesregierung im übrigen
auch nicht in anderen ländern in der
regierung
die nicht auch eingestehen müssen dass
es zu den chaotischen verhältnissen
gekommen ist hat etwas damit zu tun dass
wir alle die lage falsch eingeschätzt
haben und dass wir nicht davon
ausgegangen sind dass kabul so schnell
fällt dass die afghanischen streitkräfte
sich den taliban nicht entgegenstellen
dass der afghanische präsident gar nie
am samstag letzt vorletzten samstag das
land verlassen hat und damit die ordnung
komplett zusammengebrochen ist und die
tatsache dass wir danach schnell
entscheiden mussten wie wir mit unseren
ortskräfte umgehen und sondern schutz
sonstigen schutz bedürfen hat dazu
geführt dass ein team hat es in der
bundesregierung lange diskutiert worden
ist wie geht es mit visa und den
entsprechenden antrag stellung das haben
wir schnell weggewischt zu einem
sicherlich späten zeitpunkt aber es
braucht jetzt niemand mehr ein visa es
muss niemand eine sicherheitsprüfung
durchlaufen um nach deutschland
ausgeflogen zu werden und sicherlich ist
das einer der punkte über den wir auch
in der zukunft sprechen müssen wie diese
verfahren sind wir haben jetzt da wir
davon ausgehen dass in der nächsten zeit
auch viele afghaninnen und afghanen
nicht über den flughafen kabul sondern
über die grenze nach usbekistan
nach pakistan flüchten werden die
dortigen botschaften personell jetzt
aufgestockt das heißt es wird auch dort
möglich sein über die verfahren die wir
jetzt vereinbart haben schnell von da
aus das land verlassen zu können wenn
man zu dem kreis gehört auf denen wir
uns festgelegt haben sind über 10.000
menschen menschen die für uns gearbeitet
haben für unterschiedliche stellen der
regierung und sonstige schutzbedürftige
das sind menschenrechtsaktivisten frauen
aktivisten journalistinnen und
journalisten die bedroht worden sind
insofern es wird vieles aufzuarbeiten
geben in dem zusammenhang aber das was
jetzt notwendig ist um dafür zu sorgen
dass so viele wie möglich da raus kommen
das ist zumindest jetzt getan worden und
wird für andere die möglicherweise
ähnliche probleme hätten wie sie diese
probleme wird es nicht mehr geben und
langfristig werden wir darüber sprechen
müssen was sind die konsequenzen die
daraus zu ziehen sind und vor allen
dingen werden wir auch darüber sprechen
müssen es wird ja weitaus mehr menschen
geben die afghanistan verlassen werden
in der kommenden zeit was auf uns
zukommt welche verantwortung wir haben
wir aber auch andere in der
internationalen gemeinschaft wir danken
an dieser stelle fahrrad für seine
schilderung vielen dank herr said und
alles gute
ich habe mein bitte ich habe meine
familie
die familie sind absolut in gefahr die
haben sein haus verlassen in diesem weit
weit weg und kassel umgezogen sind weg
einfach ohne nichts wir sind wirklich
ich habe schon viele bilder habe ich
auch geschickt
weiterschicken die familie sind wirklich
labs in gefahr irgendwie auch eine
anbieter darauf man die familie helfen
können da er wie auch retten könnten aus
afghanistan nach deutschland
die sind wirklich ins gefahren also kann
man gar nicht mal erkennen wie die
taliban sind bei uns im haus
reingekommen wie das nachgefragt und man
schwangeren ich ich muss gucken wie ich
mit meinem eine jogginghose und
irgendwie auch zu starten vor dass durch
die wahl durch die bäume umsetzbaren
sich auf viele videos viele filme
handschrift wie man familie helfen
können diesen liebling erfahren und wir
wissen nicht dass dies ein paar tage
noch hammer zeit und die die telefon
funktioniert nicht wie gesagt ich bin es
auch alles weg also guthaben von handy
ist das auch genau in afghanistan kann
man nicht auf ihm gut aber noch kaufen
oder irgendwann gut wie zum beispiel
afghanische
108 gar nicht
entschuldigen sie bitte wenn ich wenn
ich hier ein haken das ist ihr schicksal
und es ist ein wichtiges schicksal das
uns alle sehr berührt aber es gibt viele
viele andere menschen auch und wir
würden kein maß auch gerne noch nach
denen befragt wie den geholfen werden
kann ganz ganz hart aber ich hätte gerne
noch einen einsatz zu herrn suite an
weil er das angesprochen hat was ich
jetzt wichtig sein wird wir werden in
den verbleibenden tagen dieser
militärischen evakuierungsaktion nicht
alle aus afghanistan raus bekommen
können das ist gebietet die ehrlichkeit
das zu sagen und deshalb brauchen wir
nach dieser evakuierung der
militärischen eine fortsetzung der
möglichkeit menschen aus afghanistan
raus zu bekommen dafür brauchen wir den
flughafen und zwar im zivilen betrieb
aber wir brauchen auch möglichkeiten die
wir jetzt mit anderen ländern absprechen
sind nicht alle in kabul und es werden
sich viele in richtung usbekistan
tadschikistan nach pakistan bewegen um
dorthin flüchten zu können und für die
brauchen wir eine option das ist das
worum es jetzt gehen wird denn wir
können wir versuchen so viele wie
möglich jetzt raus zu bringen bis zum 31
august möglicherweise aber das darf dann
nicht zu ende sein und darum bemühen wir
uns mit anderen staaten dafür zu sorgen
und darüber sprechen wir auch mit den
taliban
vollmundig erklärt haben dass auch nach
der militärischen evakuierung reguläre
ausreisen aus afghanistan möglich sind
was sarah ich wollen wir sie auch messen
und darüber sprechen wir mit ihm
zusammen mit einer maske die situation
ist ja sozusagen so dass die anderen die
regeln definieren ich bin für meine
ohren hört sich diese zivile lösung nach
der militärischen evakuierungsmaßnahmen
so an als sei es sozusagen fall schon
bald die letzte hoffnung klar das muss
man zugestehen aber man kann doch mit
taliban was haben sie in der hand sagen
sie dann also deutsche die nach
tadschikistan ausreisen dürfen sind
500.000 pro kopf 500.000 euro pro kopf
er wird doch noch einen flieger nach
deutschland nehmen darf aus dem zivilen
teil des flughafens ist eine million pro
kopf sie müssen ja irgendwas in der hand
haben gegen diese furchtbaren
terroristen die einfach den das land
abschließen werden mit unseren waffen
verteidigen werden und wir betteln dann
dass sie vielleicht den einen oder
andern noch rauslassen also dass bettelt
überhaupt niemand und ehrlich gesagt ich
glaube das größere problem besteht darin
ich glaube gar nicht dass die taliban
ist komplett verhindern können dass
menschen aus weil sie werden sich diese
riesigen grenzen dieses landes nicht
komplett dichtmachen können wir müssen
eher mit ländern reden wie usbekistan
und pakistan dass sie die menschen
überhaupt erst einmal in ihre länder
lassen dass sie dort überprüft werden
können dass sie von da aus in andere
länder ausfliegen können also im moment
ist glaube ich das größere problem dafür
zu sorgen dass diejenigen und vor allen
dingen die uns ganz besonders wichtig
sind die für uns gearbeitet haben die
auf die art und weise afghanistan
verlassen überhaupt ebendieser andere
länder reinkommen aber das bedeutet doch
wenn ich sie richtig übersetzte das
deutsche staatsbürger und die menschen
die der bundeswehr und uns geholfen
haben in den letzten jahren ab ungefähr
dem 29 august sich selbst überlassen
sind und den taliban nein das wollen wir
eben nicht und dafür müssen wir mit den
taliban reden so bitter das ist die
alternative ist sie sich selbst zu
überlassen und dazu sind wir nicht
bereit
sie haben es selber gesagt es gebe
nichts zu beschönigen man muss es so
sagen ihre amtszeit endet mit einem
desaster wir hatten gestern die
verteidigungsministerin hier annegret
kramp karrenbauer die gesagt hat dass
sie wenn die amtsperiode vorbei ist sehr
in sich gehen werde um zu prüfen welche
verantwortung sie übernimmt ob sie
nochmal falls die möglichkeiten ergeben
in einer neuen regierung zur verfügung
stehen ich weiß dass auch sie sagen
werden natürlich geht es jetzt darum die
konkrete situation zu handeln aber
trotzdem sie könnten auch jetzt hier an
dieser stelle sagen dass sie in einer
neuen regierung sollte die spd daran
beteiligt sind die verantwortung an
diesem punkt dann übernehmen also
scheint sich deutlich mehr gedanken über
meine politische zukunft zu machen als
ich es tue ich ob sie es glauben oder
nicht ich verschwende keine sekunde und
keinen gedanken im moment aber sie
bekommen doch diesen druck sie bekommen
bis jeden tag gesagt sie lesen dass
jeden tag in der zeitung ich glaube
nicht dass sie keinen gedanken daran
verschwenden dass sie unter diesem druck
stehen und das ist auch eine
erwartungshaltung gibt konsequenzen zu
ziehen also das ist definitiv so das ist
auch vollkommen legitim dass diese frage
gestellt werden auch nach der
politischen verantwortung
es ist aber auch dass es zumindest
meinem verantwortungsgefühl ich sehe
diese bilder doch genauso wie alle
anderen auch es geht auch mayr und dass
sie jetzt zurücktreten sollen sagt
überhaupt kein mensch in vier wochen ist
die legislaturperiode sowieso zu ende
aber sie könnten jetzt ein zeichen
setzen auch für eine politische kultur
und könnten jetzt sagen ich bringe das
was ich noch erledigen kann das mache
ich aber danach werde ich die
konsequenzen ziehen und werde für diesen
posten nicht mehr zur verfügung stehen
sollte er auf mich zukommt also seien
sie sich ganz sicher dass ich das was
ich jetzt tun kann tun werde
ich meine zu glauben dass es uns darum
geht irgendwie noch 30 tage minister zu
bleiben also der auffassung kümmern sei
ich habe immer gesagt jetzt es geht um
die zeit danach sollten sie die option
haben das außenministerium weiter zu
führen falls die spd an der regierung
beteiligt ist sie können heute sagen
spätestens bei übernehme ich die
verantwortung und stehen nicht mehr zur
verfügung was die nächsten vier wochen
sind geschickt gehen immer davon aus
dass ich auch meine schlüsse daraus
ziehen würde was zurzeit geschieht und
wie damit umzugehen ist und wie auch ich
persönlich damit umgehe
herr maas
damals noch eine frage wir haben auch
viel schon jedem studio heute drüber
gesprochen wie nah ist der terror jetzt
hier für uns deutsche in unserem land
also auch das werden wir erst in den
kommenden wochen sehen der grund warum
es das militärische engagement in
afghanistan gegeben hat war das damals
die taliban al-qaida eine
operationsbasis gegeben haben wir hören
jetzt heute und in den letzten tagen
dass der irs dazu aufruft das ds kämpfer
nach afghanistan kommen sollen wenn das
so sein wird dass afghanistan wieder
eine operationsbasis für den
internationalen terrorismus wird dann
werden wir uns nicht nur wir wir werden
uns in der internationalen
staatengemeinschaft sehr ernsthaft
darüber auseinandersetzen müssen was wir
dagegen tun
und das wird sich glaube ich in den
nächsten wochen wird das deutlicher
werden wie die entwicklung in
afghanistan sind wir hören im moment
viel von den taliban dass sie eine
inklusive regierung bilden unter
einbeziehung der alten afghanischen
regierung das wird man sehen also die
moderaten worte die wir da hören ob man
den glauben kann glaube ich etwas
glauben kann es wird man erst in der
kommenden zeit sehen und aber niemand
kann glauben und man glauben kann nicht
in die zukunft verlagern glauben sie
dass jetzt also dass terroristen
erzählen die sich an nichts gehalten
haben bislang also ich glaube sowieso
nicht nur in dem fall ist sondern
aufgrund vieler erfahrungen die ich
außenpolitisch gemacht habe dass man
tatsächlich mit glauben nicht
weiterkommt es wird jetzt davon abhängen
was man sieht und was die taliban dort
machen werden und daran müssen wir unser
handeln orientieren
das werden wir beileibe nicht tun was
wir alles an wohlfeilen worten auf den
letzten pressekonferenzen in dollar oder
in kabul gehört haben sie eigentlich
irgendwann eine letzte frage die ist
aber hat haben sie eigentlich irgendwann
mal das gefühl
das ist das letzte was ich gebrauchen
kann dass diese typen mich über den
tisch ziehen und ich muss mich auch noch
über den tisch ziehen lassen als von den
verhandlern der taliban ich meine wer
lässt sich schon gerne von wem auch
immer über den tisch ziehen im moment
ist es aber ganz einfach so dass es
darum geht menschen da rauszubringen
menschen zu retten und dafür müssen wir
bereit sein auch mit denjenigen zu reden
die dafür gebraucht werden das ist
leider so und das ist ein ergebnis von
vielen fehleinschätzungen
zu verweigern zu verhandeln aus
grundsätzlichen erwägungen und damit das
leben von menschen zu riskieren das
hielte ich für
unverantwortlich und zu kommt zu unseren
bedingungen kommen wir mit militärischen
maßnahmen zu euch halten sie für abwegig
also ich habe im moment dort eine
vielzahl von deutschen staatsbürgern
immer noch dort sind deutsche bundeswehr
soldatinnen und soldaten deutsche
diplomatinnen und diplomaten
und wir werden alles daran setzen die
aus dem land zu bekommen beziehungsweise
dafür zu sorgen in den kommenden wochen
auch weiter darüber zu verhandeln
wie ist es wirklich die anzahl derer die
wir nicht rausgeben auch in den
kommenden wochen raus bekommen und dafür
müssen wir wege gehen die sich niemand
gewünscht hat aber
diese wege nicht zugehen würde bedeuten
die menschen im stich zu lassen und das
werden wir nicht tun letzte frage von
mir wenn sie ein kontingent von 100
haben die man noch rausholen kann und
sie haben 100 deutsche staatsbürger und
100 afghanische orts helfer gehen die
deutschen dann zuerst wir sind sogar
dazu verpflichtet die deutschen
staatsbürger zu evakuieren gott sei dank
ist es bisher gelungen und das ergibt
sich aus den zahlen wir haben
mittlerweile über 2000 afghanische
bürgerinnen und bürger aus dem land
gebracht und 351 deutsche staatsbürger
die operation werden heute und morgen
und in den kommenden tagen so lange es
geht weiter gehen zum glück waren wir
bisher noch nicht in der situation aber
ich will das mal sagen diejenigen die
für uns da stehen sowieso sowohl die
noch von der botschaft dageblieben
gewesen sind aber auch die von der
bundeswehr die müssen jeden tag eine
entscheidung treffen an einer schleuse
wer kommt rein und wir nicht und diese
entscheidung haben wir schon getroffen
ist sind deutsche staatsbürger ist in
staatsbürger anderer
länder und es sind die neben die
nachweisen können dass sie einmal für
uns gearbeitet haben oder einen bezug zu
deutschland haben und die die wir kennen
die als menschenrechtler die als frauen
aktivisten jetzt konkret bedroht sind
und insofern wir müssen jeden tag die
leute die dort vom tor stehen und das
ist eine schreckliche aufgabe deshalb
werden etwa die bundeswehr soldaten
regelmäßig ausgetauscht weil die
psychische belastung dessen was die da
sehen es ist alles fürchterlich aber wir
treffen jeden tag diese entscheidung wer
kommt rein und wer kommt nicht und das
sind wirklich schreckliche szenen die
sich da abspielen für kraft und viel
erfolg wir wünschen ihnen eine
glückliche hand vielen dank für ihren
besuch hier bei uns im studio
[Musik]